hi for screen junkies movie fights
today's episode of movie fights is
brought to you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
rights welcome everybody
guess what we're doing it again and this
show oh it's not just gonna be fun but
it might just get intense up in here
because we have the three top contenders
before the movie fights championship
which is currently held by a felted
friend don't call him a puppet named
cucumber I think his name is
that's weird if you're just joining us
there's no idea about that yeah this is
the truth but we've the three top
contenders who are all jonesing for that
belt and ready to answer some movie
fights questions to the best of their
abilities let's meet him shall we first
up oh he's a good friend of the show
he's one of the co-hosts of Marvel movie
news he's a bon vivant and gentlemen
please welcome Quay Chandra I am so into
people I love to fight I'm very excited
about this game in particular like I've
been I've been gearing up I'm ready I'm
is got a comic-con Z that's awesome I'm
so happy to hear that but I just got a
call from the schmoes and they're upset
that you called us your favorite
we love you we let a small koi
thanks for being here brother this guy
always brings the pain he is an esteemed
nerd I would like to welcome the nerd
goat himself for the host of the nerd
goat podcast at Greer thank you guys so
much for having me again I love to
battle coy we seem to be on a defiant
one situation no bunny rabbits so
basically I love this game and I'm
really glad to participate in the
cucumber deathmatch oh hell yeah
and thanks for being here and this guy
oh man he wants his belt back he wants
it back real bad you know from all over
screen junkies SJ news and from holding
all sorts of movie related game titles
mr. dan merle been wandering in the
desert how grab that belt back but I
have to defeat these two very worthy and
formidable opponents first so this is no
walk in the park this could be tough
no sir pow pow or maybe a walk in the
park if that was a really dangerous
party dangerous Park yeah style Park
dan excited to see this epic smackdown
and deciding this battle is going to be
three judges myself and the damn cam
which there's a one on the Dan cam right
now LAN Harris in the mag checking seat
long went on brother I should leave it's
I think we should have a Dan here we
should find another dad it's too late
this is us creator Dan Fogelman doing
today
yeah or Disney Channel dan Schnur always
great to have you and the voice of the
people
she is a just a woman of many talents
welcome Danielle Radford as per usual um
so as you all know the way this works is
that in the case that there is a lock up
or a tie that is walk up a lock up now
I'm just being offended I went to Paris
no I ain't got no manners
the way this will work there there are
gonna be some really fun poles in other
ways you can participate on the movie
fights live hashtag on Twitter I'll also
be looking for funny funny memes funny
funny comments any kind of insightful
comment as well but if you are looking
for the official poll that will be the
one that goes up once all three fighters
have presented their initial arguments
and then you will get to weigh in and if
we do it because we want to make sure
that it's about the arguments not just
about which movie that you like if you
have any questions about how that works
going down to the description below or
you can ask someone in the chat Thank
You Danielle you're the best is is
before we jump into the fun the
professor lon Harris is going to school
us about a little something professor
take it away so we do want to before we
get to our first round we want to give a
shout out to our good friends over at
Squarespace they are sponsoring today's
show and if you didn't know already they
are the place to go if you want to
create your online identity and that's
whether it's a side hustle
whether it's your main gig your personal
brand whatever you need Squarespace is a
place to go to do it it has never been
easier to sell products or services
online and Squarespace is an all-in-one
platform providing 24-hour customer
support and there's nothing to install
patch or upgrade ever not ever so make
sure to check out squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace comm slash
screen junkies squarespace.com slash
screen junkies
you'll save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain wow that's so
nicely put thank you last time I did
that I feel like I went a little fast so
I tried this time very deliberately to
slow down I thought you did a fine job
I look forward to us building our
website dedicated to owls we share a
love and enthusiasm for owls
yes discovered that's a call back that I
should stop calling back I don't never
know thank you I appreciate that
professor jte
you know what are we waiting for let's
drop that package
ladies and gents
[Music]
Thank You jte for always be willing
being willing to show us your awesome
package alright let's get to a question
number one MGM has announced that
Chucky's getting a root reboot
everything's getting rebooted this
what's the all-time greatest slasher
franchise considering all of the films
together okay so all the films of that
franchise who is the what is the
all-time greatest slasher franchise Khoi
starting with you so we're talking
all-time great is considering all of
them so I'm talking consistency I'm
talking goodness I'm talking rewatch
ability I'm talking Flair and flavor I'm
talking of course about Wes Craven's
scream and evolution in horror films a
movie that not only references classic
horror films but becomes a classic
horror film this is a movie that did
meta before it was popular this is a
movie that was self-aware before it was
cool this is a movie that introduced us
to a to new type of horror film that is
still referenced to this day this is a
movie franchise that is so good that it
not only survived a reboot it survived
an entire franchise of movies
referencing it the scary movie franchise
and kept going and getting better the
first film does an amazing job of being
self referential of past horror films
the second film does an amazing job of
being referential of the first film the
third film does an amazing job of being
referential of legacy and the fourth
after a decade and not existing does a
great job of referencing reboots the
scream franchise touches on everything
while being scary while having a good
villain while having great twists while
balancing comedy and horror and while
having the right amount of sex without
being gratuitous but also balancing the
fear being real it's very hard to
balance like sex comedy scares off and
have a good villain and have a good
twist screen does it and it does it
consistently for for movies and it did
the best slasher franchise alright
coming in guns blazing with scream and
what do you got well I have I think the
standard-bearer
of the genre it has the most movies I do
believe in its franchise history it's
shown an immense malleability of concept
and that is Friday the 13th now let me
tell you a little story about Friday the
guys front of the 13th when Sean
Cunningham the director came up with the
idea he was for another movie he comes
up with this idea at the 13th this other
movie I'm trying to do I'm pitching it
all over the town I can't sell this
Friday the 13th I could sell anything
with this title and true indeed he buys
a big ad and Variety puts it in there in
front of the 13th scariest horror movie
of all time
foreign distributors all types of people
come to him with money wanting to get in
on this motion picture that is how
magnetic the concept of Friday the 13th
is in and of itself it supported over 20
movies it seems like it's had crossovers
with other things it's it's inspired
other movies you don't mean
so I'll rest on that just know the
Friday the 13th is the bones upon which
a lot of these movies are built all
right thank you sir Dan I had one choice
for this and it wasn't even close I
think by far the best slasher franchise
bar none is Nightmare on Elm Street
I think movie to movie it is the most
unique they stand out the most they
don't rely on tropes and on just falling
back on the genre as some of these other
films I think and these two franchises
have done I think that as with every
franchise even some of the best
franchises yes quality will vary as you
go but I think that every single movie
in The Nightmare on Elm Street franchise
has something to offer and I would also
offer that the franchise itself is as
coy said this was a franchise that was
self-aware way before screen was
self-aware both it both specifically in
one of their movies but I think
generally and that they took the
character of Freddy Krueger they
transformed him into a pop icon and then
through the movies themselves they
became a reflection of what the movies
were doing which i think is what makes
it so unique and the best out of all of
them all right three different
franchises three cool answers let's
fight it out so I think that all of
these films have had a quasi sequel
reboot rehash all of them have had that
movie that came well after one of them
was good not only did these guys have
Freddy and Jason together that failed
they also had a nightmare in Elm Street
that was not only offensive but very
nerving that ruined everything and the
Friday the 13th that came out nobody
really remembers the nightmare of
franchise has a ton of weekend Rees
Freddy vs. Jason didn't even get the
real Jason Mewes scream got the real
Jason Mewes and it didn't even try the
Freddy remake was not a movie that wants
to be considered a horror franchise it
just felt uncomfortable and then you've
got one of the best Nightmare on Elm
streets is the dream master and the next
movie dream story D values that by
killing the final girl and disrespected
so movie and Nightmare two breaks all
the first ones rules this franchise is
so inconsistent that when the first
sequel came out the first movie all the
rules are minima the second Nightmare
movie is about someone getting possessed
and becoming a monster it doesn't deal
with dreams that's how we can system
that franchises you say inconsistent I
say innovative the second Nightmare on
Elm Street movies is one of the most
unique horror movies ever made and
people always go down and put it down
and say like it's terrible
the second Nightmare on Elm Street movie
is I will argue one of the only slasher
films that actually operates better as a
subtle metaphor for closeted and
homosexuality they cast a male in the
role that's usually cast for a female
and as much scratch as people talk about
Nightmare on Elm Street 2 and again this
goes back to the further point of the
Nightmare on Elm Street series it is
absolutely wholly unique in the genre
and that's what keeps the Nightmare on
Elm Street series alive and fresh bored
of the bones if it changes its own rules
but you're talking about you talking
about stuff that stands the test of time
and stuff that some again a malleable
concept
Jason's fought pyrokinetics he's went to
New York and had a slice of pizza and
knocked that guy's head off into a trash
can he's good in the outer freakin space
we're talking about a franchise that can
support all of these different
adventures and yes this guy isn't as
interesting as a guy with a thousand
fathers which you can't have a thousand
followers it's the one sperm that gets
their man
while the rest is just decoration
horrible decoration but decoration
nonetheless now look man I just feel as
though some of you some of these a
pedophile and a set of you know self
reverential kids cannot compare to an
elemental death monster that comes due
to go away from Jason's break into a
light jog you we're going to fall asleep
it doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter where you go it doesn't matter
what you try your body is going to
sacrifice it is going to betray you and
Freddy's gonna get you and again that's
why that what I think makes Freddy
Krueger so primal Jason Jason can kill
back Jason can kill the people who
believe in Freddy thus giving Freddy his
powers this was proven in the crossover
that they had when Jason went to a
Nightmare on Elm Street town I started
killing all the fools that believed and
Freddy much like any God when you kill
all their believers he dies what nobody
believes in Jason he's still truckin
beta and he crew her owned Jason when
Freddy fought him on his turf mystical
magical fairy land
Freddy you just said her are they'll
always get you but in the second movie
nothing follows own rules and Jason's
rules he's guarding Crystal Lake that
makes the Manhattan one irrelevant and
Jason in space is not cool kills and fun
times and originality and surprising
people and that's where I have it with
scream the first scream is definitely a
breath of fresh air however if people
had actually remembered a few years
earlier when they saw the first scream
and talked about how cool it was that it
was meta and self-aware yeah there was
another movie directed by Wes Craven
that came out a few years before scream
it was called new nightmare it was the
first horror movie that was meta and
self-aware and deconstructing the horror
franchise and it is one of the best
films in the nightmare gnomes okay okay
guys guys I'm over here listen to you
guys jerk off over marinus and I'm
telling you meat and potatoes death is
what I'm selling over here I mean
potatoes wait a minute your stuff is
just like a kick-ass right kick-ass
spent its whole runtime going this is a
realistic movie if you're trying to
fight crime to get beat up and the
ten minutes he jumps it to a jetpack rig
and shoots everybody with a bond device
it violates its own rules much in that
respect the realism that made the first
screen very good boy that deteriorated
very fast throughout the rest of the
series thus violating its central tenets
in much the same way that you're saying
uh my mine are and nightmares our thing
about Jason that stands out as special
his deaths are anyone can kill someone
like Jason all of the horror movies can
kill someone like Jason and the mom
twist and the first one is the best one
because it's unexpected and then they
just betray that for the second third
fourth fifth the best Jason movie is
like the fifth one in the franchise and
then it falls apart again the deaths in
the last two installments weren't
memorable I can't name a bunch of Jason
deaths cuz it's a guy with the machete
that isn't that scary nightmares at
least scary cuz it's different but I
think the nightmare element is that it
has rules and if it betrays then what's
the point it's not about the rules and
you're right it is about the
meat-and-potatoes death which again my
movie has stabbed Jason how many people
does need to chop with a machete or
throw down some stairs or whatever hit
with the tree every single death and
Nightmare on Elm Street is memorable
every single death is choreographed like
that's the centerpiece of the franchise
and when you get into the middle of it
you know 1 & 2 you have some really
horrific body horror dust you get into 3
4 & 5 those death scenes are some of the
best surrealism that we've seen I didn't
even not even just in horror but in like
the 80s motion picture period the way
that those are choreographed that's
what's memorable about it they took
Freddy as from the monster they took him
to the pop icon the film's acknowledge
that then it gets meta and self-aware
but and they deconstruct one thing I
would say though is it does with
Freddy's funniness I think he's really
he violates a lot of the central tenets
of what makes things funny
I wish use me makes things scary over
the course of most movies in scream at
least for the for the whole first movie
I was scared by the end of the first
even movie kind of woman I don't say
that I mean the second and third movie
certainly Freddy was starting to get
more funny than scary and when he's
walking down the street with these big
giant paper mache arms you can call that
innovative or you can call that stupid
as hell free throw on set coy go ahead
and make this your final hot and we'll
go around get final thoughts from
everybody final thoughts slasher films
horror films the end of they are
supposed to be scary we know what Jason
is we know he's coming we know
gonna lumber at us very slowly the end
of the day we know who Freddie is we
know what the cabbie outs are we know
all that my franchise the only one that
has twists that actually make it matter
you don't know who's next to you you
don't know if it's the scream killer the
first three films are so innovative in
the killer and then the fourth one ups
the bar even more you never know who the
killer is you never know what's coming
and you never know what to expect from
screen
you know to expect for all these films
or you're betrayed by the fact that they
don't even listen their own stuff thank
you II D floor is yours
again what you might call a standard
predictable fare I say is it's a and
it's inexorable Jason is almost a
metaphor for the unfairness of death
you're chilling out trying to have some
sex in the woods like a regular teenager
should and this stumbles on
blocks you with a machete hey you know
it's just nuts it's it's its unfairness
incarnate right his death was unfair as
a little kid the some camp counselors
who his mom was killing kill his mom and
now he has to stick to the revenge plan
baby and he's locked in this inexorable
cycle coming out of the swamp to kill
these kids again and again it's a real
metaphor for a lot of things and over
the course of the movie it was an
allegory for many different things so I
just feel like it's an enduring horror
concept and it's it's the best out of
these especially with funny boy over
here hey thank you dan Merle here's the
secret about slasher films at some point
you're rooting for the killer and friend
Nightmare on Elm Street was the only
genre that actually acknowledged that
and said the star of the movie isn't
whoever is out there stalking or
whatever faceless person we got to star
in this franchise it's Freddy Krueger we
know where our bread is buttered and
we're gonna lean into it and they did
that brilliantly they reinvented him as
he became more and more popularly
reinvented him for the 90s they put him
up with Jason and that was a success it
did do very well I think that's a fun
movie it's a movie that I enjoy a lot
they did a remake it wasn't great he did
a remake that wasn't great scream for he
called it an evolution in horror film
it's a de-evolution in horror film
because it became what it was parody and
the first one by the time you got to the
fourth one Freddy's the one that stays
original all the way through if you want
to know who the killer is and screamed
for have Sidney take a blood test with
whoever it is that's in the cast goes
it's someone it's in her family
in a row and Jason again just jog away
from him
Freddie's gonna get you and he's gonna
get you in a creative way that's why I
love Nightmare on Elm Street time all
right
Wow well fought you guys I mean I was
just sitting here just like listening to
all the points you're making and I'm
like this is such a great conversation
about like really well played any facts
couple facts and so it did come up like
ooh who's the most killing us slasher
okay so I look that up in tone in terms
of body count
Jason is running away with this with 145
kills in the Friday the 13th series go
space in the screen films 41 is the West
grave and approved death count Freddy
only 35 that's pretty much where
surgical he's and he's really deserved
Surgical with this sheet yeah a few more
a few more quick facts yeah we talked
about how many films in the franchise's
total and was correct 12 movies in the
Friday the 13th franchise makes it the
leader out of all these the other only
the only other one that gets there is
puppet master also 12 films well there's
Wow so those were your for how many
leprechauns are there oh I have one
factual question at one time he said
Jason Mewes I'm Jason Voorhees no Jason
yo J and site on the screen franchise
cuz knew I'd owned the both it was a
funny cameo I had a fake Jason Mewes guy
Jason and Freddy and it was like this
poor man's Jason Mewes know stuff that
was funny they couldn't get him but
screamed that's funny
got juice okay noted like I said before
this this was an amazing conversation
you all came with serious knowledge and
really broke down the horror genre and
where your franchise stands in the
horror genre koi I feel like you got
knocked down a little bit by Edie who
talked about your franchise violating
its own rules a little bit and it's not
having the consistency of the other
franchises in terms of
some of the kills and some of that the
inventiveness along the way but but you
made great points but I feel like to me
it came down to Edie and Dan with Friday
the 13th and Nightmare on Elm Street and
I feel like Dan just made the stronger
case as far as his franchise being more
unique movie to movie Freddy being so
compelling and then being self
referential and playing with the idea of
who Freddy was yeah it was a damn good
fight but my vote goes to Dan Merle on
this lawn so ultimately I agree I think
it really came down to sort of Edie
versus Dan and I think they both made a
lot of great points but ultimately I
thought Dan had a couple really good
points that just went kind of unanswered
I thought the new nightmare coming out
two years before the scream films that
that really took coy down I had really a
good unanswered point about that
franchise actually going sort of meta
first at but I thought the real killer
point was you do you end up rooting for
the killer in these movies and the
Nightmare on Elm Street films they're
the only ones that have really soaked
that into their bones made Freddy the
hero so I'm gonna go Dan all right Dan
you take the point first question out of
the gate what they said on that YouTube
hole that the poll agrees the poll has
got Nightmare on Elm Street at 65%
scream at 23% and Friday the 13th at 11%
yeah that's a little disrespectful of
Friday one percent for a movie Elmo
he's not guarding Crystal Lake it's like
revenge against horny teenagers yeah
it's not like one of the owls who is
Guardians
out like a bouncer like any other fun
ideas out there for best horror
franchise that wasn't mentioned by a lot
of people were like Halloween yeah we
have some people come through with
Hellblazer we had a lot of people coming
through with Evil Dead yeah those were
those were kind of it those are the
biggies awesome final destination with
death as the concept as a slasher I
almost asked if I could do fidelity like
that's an easy thing to chop your legs
off if someone's like that doesn't count
so yeah we would have probably counted
final this movie fights
trucks yeah yeah a highway with lobby
trucks or those swings back or whatever
well I've just had a great comment that
I just want to make sure everyone heard
know snuff films on question number two
Dan Merle out to a 1-0 lead okay
the new film eighth grade is getting
really great reviews who gives the best
child actor performance in any movie
ever wow this is a great question who
gets the best kid actor performance in
any movie ever we are going to start
with player number two because it's
question number two ahead well I think
this is a really interesting choice my
choice was a Natalie Portman and the
professional I believe for a bunch of
reasons one of which she actually
grounds the film I think this might be
the best performance I love a luc besson
as a director but this this particular
performance seems like a lot of her she
seems to be very much acting and one
thing I'd like to establish is part of
my criteria for judging this is the
actual acting ability of the child there
are certain you know acting performances
that are basically parlor tricks or kids
being kind of psychologically coerced
into some weird semblance of reality you
know like hey yeah I'm gonna punch your
mom if you don't look at this alien or
whatever you know I mean and I just feel
like now that important is really acting
I really feel as though she understands
what she's doing she's not being just
you know psychologically prodded I
really believe like she understands how
important her performance is to this
motion picture and I think that's a real
criteria for best kid performance thank
you by the way law and I want you to
fact-check directors threatening
the truth Bank me would tell someone oh
your dog just died and that's a real
thing got it
I'm on up next Dan I feel like it was
targeting me because my take his hit is
my biggest Henry Thomas who does share
screen time with an extraterrestrial for
much of its picking boys pic coming up
you know there's no you can't make an
argument these are any of them bad
performances so it's really just kind of
going on how I register it and how it
hits me when I see a film and I look at
Henry Thomas and I think that when you
have child actors it's sort of just like
expected that like oh just act childlike
just you know there are kids right but
like it's not that easy it's actually
pretty hard for kids particularly to act
like kids on screen and I think Henry
Thomas is able to pull off so many
different sides of his character he does
have a childlike side but he's also a
child of divorce you can kind of see
that weighing on him a little bit and
then he has this this incredible thing
happened to him and and just the the the
emotions that this movie puts him
through just you know the the fear the
terror the Wonder the joy the heartbreak
the sadness the grief like it's none of
it is is scene-stealing none of it seems
kind of cloying or or sappy like you can
get with kid actors it's very
naturalistic childlike performance and
the whole movie I think really rests on
it and that's always impressed me and
it's always the performance that kind of
comes to mind when I think of actors in
this genre or you know of this age so
that's my pick alright Henry Thomas in
ET background a Koi there are certain
performances that when you see them
there's the new bar that is set like
when I think of what like a Heath Ledger
did with the Joker and when I think of
like you know Marlon Brando in The
Godfather and only one kid ever has done
that for me only one kid I didn't
categorize it as a child performance I
was just like this changes my opinions
on performance and that's Abraham Atta
in beasts of no nation and this is a
movie that worst case scenario I lose
this in
higher flight more people watch piece of
nomination because this is a kid in this
movie isn't just a child he ages 20
years before our eyes I have never seen
anything like what this kid accomplishes
Abraham otta goes from being a happy
child to orphaned to unwilling soldier
to willing soldier to mercenary before
our eyes if you watch the trailer in two
and a half minutes you can see a boy
lose his innocence and steal scenes from
a Juris Elba no one can steal scenes
from Aegis Elba a freaking child does
beasts of no nation it's such a hard
subject matter you see children murdered
you see the actual depths of depravity
of humankind and the whole time you're
seeing it through the eyes of a child
and your mourning his innocence while
going what's gonna happen next he
carries an ak-47 with more weight than
I've seen any action movie do he carries
the depths of killing more than I've
seen adult performers do Abraham Atta
shouldn't have just won the Oscar he
should be considered Marlon Brando level
in one role because I've never in my
life seen someone lose the light in
their eyes and then he shows up in
spider-man home companies like hey I'm a
kid I was like what I thought he was an
actual child they found and abused but
because it would betray the movie
because this to me is seeing someone
lose their innocence and to me is the
depths of performance that there's the
evolution from child to adult that's
doing horrible things
all right fight it out everybody well
impassioned as that was and boy I want
people it was it was beautiful I mean I
was f lee Bailey asking but the thing is
I want more people to watch that movie
but it does have a few crutches that
help the performance one big thing is
voiceover that kid has more voiceover
than Ray Liotta and and it really sets
the table for the subtle acting choices
that he does employ in the selling of
this and obviously the subject matter is
so huge and so visceral and so dramatic
for lack of a better word that it also
helps the performance I this this trifle
of a French assassin movie that that
that Natalie Portman grounds with with
the gravitas of her parents getting
killed by police
and her having to go to an assassin and
her selling us on that fanciful concept
I just feel like that's a big acting
challenge you know I mean rather than
something that's so real and so grounded
in it and of itself so I do believe he
had some help I mean it's definitely an
acting challenge but I've also kind of
felt like when you talk about key to the
movie what's endured over the movie and
again we're splitting hairs here because
these are the three really good
performances but when I watch the
professional eye I kind of feel like she
is one element of that film but I think
you also have another completely almost
sort of separate element with Gary
Oldman and Jean Renault and their kind
of thing going on over here and then you
have Natalie Portman going on over here
and she's great in the movie but I'm
looking at the movie and how does
everything sort of lock together while
she's great I don't you know other than
sort of allowing it to be grounded a
little bit and humanize him a little bit
because he is Jean Renault is such a
kind of a removed character I don't
think it's as integral on this key to
the movie as Henry Thomas is for et
because literally the whole movie rests
on his shoulders and really his
shoulders alone his co-star for most of
the movie is a piece of rubber with a
with a person inside of it it's it's
something that you know it not only does
he not have a co-star he doesn't have a
co-star like an inter cell but he
doesn't have a co-star like his genre
know to play off of he's playing off of
a puppet it's probably usually half
there somebody's smoking under the table
I don't know you know you're going on
this journey with them and even in the
process of making the movie you don't
even have that support system as far as
obviously you have great directors at
the helm for all of these but you don't
have the rest of that net that I think
that these performances had for from for
me when I think of I love Lee I'm a
professional but when I think of her
performance she's playing an archetype
she's not playing a fleshed out
character she's playing Jodie Foster and
taxi driver she's playing a thing we've
seen before and she does it very well
but if you actually watch that with
scrutiny it's not as layered as it's
very it's it's a performance that is
that thing if you remember Lee under
pressure you're like that is what a
child put in that situation is doing it
never is more than that to me and I
remember Gary Oldman's
everyone and your honor no being this
cartoon and she does bring all that
together to a point but it's very this
is the role she needs to play for me
Henry Thomas was I remember Reese's
Pieces I remember all of the kids movie
I remember drew Barrymore I remember the
imagery
I don't remember Henry Thomas doing a
lot I remember him being there and to me
Henry Thomas plays a role that as a kid
in imagination he's playing a wide-eyed
kid I was a kid that imagine an alien
friend my character is imagining killing
people and it starts out with him as
innocent as your character and ends as
destroyed as your character my character
is the arc between our two characters
and he does it with such depth that
there's no way to see that person as
anything except the cat that's saying
that that Elliot and Henry Thomas that
they don't have an arc and they
absolutely do have an arc he does start
as just a kid and you go from the
beginning that movie and then the last
shot of that movie the last shot of ET
it's it's on it's his face it's
Elliott's face and you can see on his
face no words no voice over nothing what
this experience has done to him he looks
adult he was kind like you're saying he
looks grown-up he looks at matured he
this thing has changed him and you see
that on his face and again to say
wide-eyed kid like that does a great
disservice to what his performances he's
not just playing a wide-eyed kid he
loses his best friend and gets him back
we'll sees things that he never thought
he much did much in that same way
calling calling what Natalie Portman did
some aunjanue performance is really
reductive because what she does is show
you that this Neverland Ranch ass
without a professional dude right he's
got the he's got he's got the kid but
it's the thing is for the people who
believe that Michael Jackson was
innocent he's just a kid he see he sees
her doing Marilyn Monroe and dressing up
in all this different stuff and he just
sees another kid because he never had a
chance to grow up he's drinking freakin
milk at 45 after he's killed 500 people
he's a baby in his head and he's got
this other character to ground him to
much like Kurt Rambis for the old Lakers
tie that team together as a glue guy
she's the glue guy of a very fanciful
kind of ridiculous movie and it's still
one of Lucas ons best movies because he
never I don't think again had somebody
tied together all the ridiculousness he
throws at the wall the way that she did
in this movie so I think it is a little
bit
deductive to call her just sort of an
ingénue about a minute left so let's
just a free-for-all here if anybody has
a point they want to get across get it
in I think that it's easy to convey
emotion through tragedy and that's what
both of these performances are it's as
these kids that have gone through
tragedy and tragic events in their lives
and I think it is much harder to
paradoxically it's harder to be an every
kid and every man you know somebody
who's just an average kid that you'd see
on the street who has these
extraordinary things happen to him I
think it is it is more difficult to pull
off and I think that it is a harder
thing than sort of these things that
like you get audience sympathy through
tragedy and I think you have to gain
earn that more oh I would say just once
once again to ground this where our
understand this kid's gonna get mad
askers but now the that appointment is
an actual actor and looks at her Oscar
every day this kid sells insurance I
don't know these two films they have
cult followings for a reason et is about
the imagery it's about the iconography
it's about what Spielberg made you feel
it's about that emotion it's not about
his performance when you look at the
professional you remember these iconic
moments you remember the Ron Dios nature
of what luc besson assembled you
describe half of your last argument was
about how good John Renault was not even
about Natalie Portman I feel like it's a
piece of a puzzle but she's not the core
he's not the core my character without
my my character you have no eyes into a
party she's an emotion
good stuff good stuff good stuff fellas
Claude Harris please go ahead and give
us some factual ''tis and then weigh in
with your opinion Jerry's not not a lot
of facts to correct huh we do know Henry
Thomas it's gone viral he had a very
impressive audition for ET so he was not
tormented on set congratulations you got
the job watching it if you haven't seen
it also three actors did bring ET to
life two of them were little people one
of them was a 12 year old actor who was
born without legs he would walk around
on his arms and that's what gives et his
sort of unique gait in some of those
seats so that bring that up these are
these are three great performances these
are three amazing movies if you haven't
seen beasts of no nation I highly
recommend the it's really genetic
ultimately I thought you know COI had so
many good points the passion of it I
thought he really brought everything
together really well and I think
ultimately the point that the film is
centered on Abraham Atta these other
films there's a lot of memorable
elements there's a lot of things that
people sort of picked up on in that film
that whole movie really does rise and
fall on that performance so I'm going
with koi lon
you know what I don't want to I don't I
don't want to be a puppet here and or
Amarra or some kind of canary or her and
just echo what you said but like you
kind of reach into my brain and grab a
lot of thoughts that I have I thought
coy really waged an argument here about
just taking us on that journey through
this child's face through this child's
performance through his acting then and
just you know I was and I was
visualizing it as you were talking about
it I'm like yeah and so Dan and Edie
both made great cogent arguments but man
you really just like
yeah you really you really sold it so it
goes to koi and really gets the point
looking at the polls the audience agrees
they had beasts of no nation is Abraham
outside with 46% the these were
incredibly close Henry Thomas for et at
28% in the Natalie Portman Leon the
professional 25% some other things that
people brought up kirsten dunst an
interview with the vampire Haley Joel
Osment The Sixth Sense I bring a Mac and
me Jodie Foster and taxi driver Johnny
Keane and Logan and then Bryan on
Twitter who goes at gunner 921 says the
baby and babies day out that baby did
all its own stunts
I saw ET and and like the two most
classic cult movies about children I was
like what do I do I always picked Linda
Blair toss-up for me maybe I should've
gone the other way dad anyone online did
you say Anna Paquin did anyone mention
an opacity when Harvey Keitel's ding
dong that's true all right
it's COI one dad one ed yet to get on
the board and we go to question number
three the Joker
origin movie it's official what a Batman
villain deserves a standalone origin
movie oh yes and we are opening up one
of the great rogues galleries of all
time maybe the greatest to explore and
pick our villain all right what Batman
villain deserves a standalone movie damn
it's gonna sound like a joke but it's
not
I looked through the rogue's gallery and
I went with a villain that is not a
household name but one that I thought
was very intriguing he's a villain named
calendar man
here's what I love about calendar man he
is obsessed with numbers just like me
he is s twith heists and planning
elaborate crimes they always coordinate
with certain days of the month with
holidays things like that everyone is
unique and the other thing that I love
is that he's not a particularly good
criminal but he gets by an enthusiasm
and heart and I think I want to see this
side of the back universe after so long
of seeing these villains who are
growling at the camera and scowling in
the shadows in a world such as Gotham
City you are going to have criminals who
are on the wrong side of the law but
gosh darn it are they trying hard and
they don't all need to be trying to
destroy the world and they don't all
need to be have have plans of world
domination and I think this would be
dare I say it kind of a fun movie in the
Batman universe all right
Dan coming in with Calendar man pack
around a koi
I picked the Moriarty - Batman Sherlock
I picked the yin to the yang of the
world's greatest detective I want a
movie to focus on the mind of the Batman
I want Riddler man I want a guy who's
gonna I want to believe that as equal
parts neo noir and 7 I want a movie that
makes you think and discern and digest
and be disgusted but also invested I
want a movie where you're studying the
mind of Batman I want prisoners by way
of Batman and the best man for that job
is the Riddler the Riddler's
underappreciated we've had a Jim Carrey
Rinzler ne7 put Jim Carrey and something
it's Jim Carrey by way of it's not the
character it's Jim Carrey's
blankety-blank just like Jack
Nicholson's blankety-blank with the
Joker like that was just like the
Riddler just put on a green thing I want
people to know who the Riddler is so not
only is it important to the movie itself
it's important to the Batman mythos this
is the only character I feel like hasn't
gotten his comeuppance he hasn't gotten
the respect he deserves and dare I say
he's the only mind that is stronger than
Batman's he's not trying to dominate the
world necessarily he just wants to out
think the smartest detective in the
world and the Riddler would be
some movie that is small that is nuanced
that is intelligent and that can be
challenged in the audience with Sorkin s
dialogue didn't evil a new F directing
and just something that's so different
smart taught and a new Batman which we
need all right thank you coy Edie I
thought long and hard about the person I
was going to bring for this battle
because I wanted to present somebody
whose actual origin I would want to see
and a person whose origin could even
make one two three movies even a person
you could actually build something
around and the only person is raeshell
ghoul or Ra's al Ghul for the other
people but the bottom line is Ra's al
Ghul ratio Ghul is an amazing character
proven to be immortal he literally
bathes in a lava pit to stay young kind
of like Tom Cruise does you know he sees
one of these he's one of these just
mystical ephemeral he he commands an
army of ninjas he bathes in lava and he
only wants the best for his daughter man
you know he's just a good guy
and I really think all these people
talking about you know kill monger was
right
you know the ghost was right from
ant-man boy you talk about a villain who
may be right even though his methods are
wrong he's the ecological terrorist he's
trying to stop us from ruining the world
so it's somebody who adopted that
philosophy as much as we geeked over
Thanos or Thanos we can we can geek over
this guy's wonderful long beautiful epic
Godfather to ask fortune story all right
Wow fight it out y'all so I feel like
Ra's al Ghul's already been modernized
in a really intelligent way I feel like
we just had a Ra's al Ghul that was more
interesting than the character has been
in the comics and I also feel like it's
not an origin that we really need to see
because it's so familiar and to me the
peen of the day he's a swashbuckling guy
with a Lazarus Pit like that's a very 10
minute origin to me and he's kind of
weird to his daughter like he's abusive
and I don't want to follow a story
that's like Talia's kind of like it
doesn't seem fair to give him an origin
movie because we one just had one into
the character is so flimsy on paper for
me the calendar man is a poor man's
Riddler so I would actually love and I
thought of this before you said calendar
and that it was then it came to play as
a movie
the calendar man is an opening villain
and then have planted seeds that the
Riddler takes credit for or misleads
people on so he's like that opening
Patsy character because calendar man you
can't do an orange and much else a whole
movie against Batman Riddler is the only
one of these characters that you can
have a tech genius you have a Silicon
Valley s character you've got a newsroom
ass plot device that you follow along
and then all he wants is to be proven to
be the smartest this is a guy that just
wants to be like guys validate me that's
interesting and that's also very 2018
razzle ghoul we've seen calendar man we
haven't seen the movie we receive the
Riddler match wits against Batman I
guess I'll have to go to the comic books
or to Frank Gorshin or to Gotham
currently on the air or the Batman the
Animated Series or in a Batman Forever
the Riddler is one of the villains that
has been the most like he's smart and he
matches up well with Batman I know this
I've seen it I've seen it across many
different media and again Ra's al Ghul
I've seen the ninja as a scene Talia al
Ghul I've seen I agree with koi I liked
how they reinvented Ra's al Ghul and
again these are both movies dredged in
darkness and and shadow and it's like we
have so many of those corners that are
exposed right now in the DC Universe but
that is does what I would like to thank
you for making that point for me this
calendar man movie would be DC trying to
do ant-man and failing that's literally
yeah III think that tone is very very
tricky and and guys yes you've seen him
as a guy with a bunch of ninjas but how
does one procure a bunch of ninjas
sometime in pre no this is how you get a
bunch of ninjas sometime in prehistory
your Alexander the Great esque feats
that you do
Garner's you a cult-like respect and a
group of people breed themselves to be
your servants forever
no no Batman Begins was typical Nolan s
charlatanism where he goes just sort of
passed down with the Dread Pirate
Roberts there's no indication that he's
immortal or awesome what's your Mandarin
get your Mandarin out of my DC movie
alright this is that beta switch he
always says this just is this yeah I
know but it is it's just it's pretty
Mandarin Mandarin character he can be
Duncan he cannot be not Jim Carrey I'm
tired of these people fighting Batman
work Batman solves your trick and he
gets up to where you are he just beat
your ass I'm tired of these people being
Batman's main villains that sucks and
that's dumb how cool can give them a
fight how many times we see Batman
animation how many times have we seen
him fight a race it's gonna end in a
fight with Batman and a lot of Batman
taking and then won't even show up in
any of these movies the whole point is
these people as a standalone origin film
correct you don't need them and that's
what's great about calendar man it's
about calendar man that's what my movies
about it's about him it's about the
character it's about the guy this
argument I'm just like oh my god this
tone this tone will never work you'll
never be able to get this tone in this
universe yeah they said about Gardens
who galaxies about the talking about
in the tree that'll never work in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe guess what
it did cuz you got a great director you
made it work both of these guys haven't
been really in a movies because my man
cinema isn't kind to math problems and
writing stuff you know Santa's not kind
of plans and that's what calendar man is
thinking you love baton switches I
personally love when I'm trying to
determine what's the
kind to Lawrence of Arabia with an
undead lava piss order doobies haven't
done well in years and david fincher -
murder mysteries have at the end of the
day one of these is cinematically
charged and that is not the poor man's
room it's the ruler in fact this is the
poor man's Riddler as a matter of fact I
don't think it's the poor manager as I
said before he's not a genius but he
leaves riddles based on no Hollander no
you're taking your knowledge of him and
applying it to my project I never see
left rules he plans his elaborate heist
that are based on days of the week he
tries to pull them off use elaborate
costume sets and everything else it's a
fun movie good time villain out there
that's actually having fun being a
villain here I was like oh all that
thought I'd like to hear who do you
envision playing your villain in an
origin story take a moment and let us
have it
go Murray Bill Murray yes all right
Murray's calendar don't worry it's my
calendar man Bill Murray okay fun coy I
would like to see Michael C Hall I would
like to see Dexter but without that
horrible ending I would like to see
someone he also looks like he's got the
red hair you knew the chops I want to
see someone that you can watch think and
you be invested in it so you don't have
the math problem you have someone that
you're like oh I'm fascinated by his
choices and whether he makes the right
or wrong choice you were always on
Dexter side so someone whose pathos is
stronger than the decisions they're
making for you so you're invested in the
man that's Michael C home Edie
hmm I mean I would love I don't really
have a specific actor but and I know I'm
gonna get killed for this but somebody
with the sort of I'd like to see
somebody with a fast bender s gravitas
take on Rachel go a lot of these guys
who have played him are just more or
less some sideburns in an attitude even
to a certain extent Liam Neeson's
version of them so I really would really
like to see somebody who plays to pay
dose of somebody immortal and somebody
who truly has seen it all and I just
want to say one thing one thing please
jeez calendar man okay this is
paper-rock-scissors oh by the way let's
make this your final calendar man is a
poor man's version of this guy's
character and the Riddler the only time
in film that he's ever done anything
cool he deduced what Batman's
identity was and went into his cave and
broke all his up that is the
definition of a racial ghoul move the
best version of this character was just
aping stuff that racial ghoul is done
and his characters inferior to that
character
therefore I win all right thank you add
Dan final thought yeah
again you're both saying Oh so-and-so is
a poor man's version of that character
and I completely disagree again going
back to guardians of the galaxy that was
well they're just a poor man's Avengers
or the space Avengers what know you get
talent behind it you get it you get a
script you get a director I think Wes
Anderson would be very good for this
movie by the way I would love to see his
take on this material and you make it
unique that's what did it all of
everyone in comics is a poor man's
version of somebody how many poor man's
versions of Batman and Captain America
how many poor man's version of Superman
have been turned into great characters
look at Thor isn't he kind of a poor
man's version of Superman he's a god
coming up from on high flying around
yeah but you make him a great character
when you adapt into the cinematic form
and that's what you do as Calendar man
I'm so tired of movies that are showing
me an alternate take on things that I
already know I all I know that the
Riddler's smart this is supposed to be a
standalone origin movie and all coy
talks about is how well as mine matches
up with Batman I know that the Riddler
Batman are both smart and if they think
at each other that eventually Batman's
gonna win the thinking contest I know
that Ra's al Ghul is immortal
we've tread that ground and his daughter
and the ninjas I know that and the
audience knows that we saw what just
happened with solo people are getting
tired of seeing movies about the same
characters over and over again treading
ground that we've already tread just
with slightly 10 degrees to the left
calendar man is a different tone you can
make it work with the proper gate pans
and in the proper guidelines it is a
different kind of villain it is not the
poor man's version of The Riddler
because I think he stands out he's not
leaving riddles he's not leaving clues
you put that projection on it not me and
I think that you can have a really
unique fun villain that does you know
just these these heists these you know
not just sitting in a dark lair we have
so much of that what 7th at goes out
there and actually enjoys being a super
villain all right thank you Dan
quite so much the same way you think I
put the the riddle
your character I think you put the dark
on mine I've never seen The Riddler as a
dark character he is wearing a bright
green suit in a bowler cap and he runs
around with a cane and has high jinks
but he's not all the way Jim Carrey the
character in the comics is the only one
of these characters to have taken out
Batman he won many times he might out
think him and I'm like I'd rather see a
movie where someone is thinking their
way through problems and if he says he
doesn't do riddles what is he setting up
how is he setting up things to happen on
certain days if there's no solution he's
just like hitting mousetraps like what's
the goal of the mouth he's just landing
nice and then but he's not there's no
active action if he's just Ocean's
eleven by himself and then at the end of
the day a thinking man's movie is much
more exciting so I agree with these two
because if we're talking bout poor man's
whatever poor man's Indiana Jones that's
all todd like this guy is razzle goes
just Indiana Jones but with a Lazarus
Pit so at the end of the day I'd rather
see a Taylor Sheridan scripted David
Fincher directed movie where you're
learning about a very smart man that
wants to control the narrative of his
own life and wants to be appreciated for
being smart you don't need Batman
because all the guy wants is
justification for being smarter than
everyone around it but he's just born a
thousand-year-old Indiana Jones would be
badass
lon what's the what's the fact-check on
this not immortal his life has been
extended for hundreds of years because
of the Lazarus Pit friend we also should
add the Lazarus pick it's not lava it's
sort of one of the Lazarus is connected
to the volcanic system of an island but
the Lazarus pits are full of
life-extending chemicals they're
chemicals
Dan's claim that you can hire a bunch of
ninjas great Wow
this was this is a bang-up battle and so
right out of the gate dan I admire you
from making it just an off the beaten
track choice but I feel like you um your
arguments were great but they set you on
your heels a little bit you were forced
to defend the idea of taking
out-of-the-box choices more than you
were able to sell the character to us so
because of that for me it came down to
ed and coy and Man two very different
movies but the one who intrigued me most
and tied to the question who deserves a
standalone origin movie was Edie
okay coy really sold a fascinating film
to me I mean I wanted to I wanted to see
I want to see your movie well does you
see I want to see yesterday but your
movie and just the depths of Ra's al
Ghul's world explored in those origins
um yeah that was the best answer for me
Ron well I have to say dan had me for
most of the time I think usually
dismiss the it's been done argument
right movie fights but in this case
there's a very compelling case to be
made because we really have never seen
anything like calendar man done we've
seen both of these other characters a
bunch of a bunch of other media I
thought that was a really compelling
argument but then when EADS started
really describing his Ra's al Ghul movie
I have to admit I was sort of won over
the the large-scale sort of adventure
sweeping adventure of it really sold me
for COI I felt like you kind of were
cross-purposes you opened with it's like
neo noir it's like seven really dark
really gritty references and then you
ended up being like no it doesn't have
to be ducting to be funny so I sort of
didn't know where to go with that so I'm
though then you and I have agreed on
everything no I read already you get the
point
Danielle what's YouTube saying alright
so as a French now um YouTube went 44%
for calendar man 8% for Riddler and 27%
raesha cool other names that were
mentioned were mr. freeze
sure hush red Red Hood those were kind
of like the biggies Ron James white also
Gator with like a four and some but g4z
Oh r24 said look we all know who the
real Batman villain is Joel Schumacher I
don't agree you're both sides
oh I'm just surprised that Gator didn't
say Killer Croc that's right there
guess what y'all we are tied 1-1 1 so we
are going to the time I
Oh nicely done JT EPM johnny-on-the-spot
with that tiebreaker graphic all right
so here's how the tiebreaker works I'm
going to ask the question and then
you'll each answer and then we'll go
around and hear your aunt your
elaboration on the answers in the order
that you spoke okay and you'll each get
20 seconds to speak on your answer and
then we'll go back around same order
ten-second rebuttal and then Danielle
giving her own opinion not the Internet
so that's how long and myself we'll
decide who does not move on to the speed
round there we go and this three person
speed rap yeah basically thank you
all right here's the question henry
cavill gave a bit more insight on early
Man of Steel to discussions this week
who should be the villain in the
Superman sequel
Brainiac Brainiac
mr. mr. mixon mix-up licks an e d me say
bizarro all right so we have Brainiac
mr. mixup licks and bizarro all right
cool you know how it works 20 seconds
begin whenever you speak and again the
order will be coy dan ed we've seen
decent DC villains base their merit on
strength on going after things on these
crazy schemes I want to see it based on
smarts and smarts alone Brainiac is
brilliant he's visually stunning he
brings an alien this to it I want to see
more of the outside world Superman plus
I wanna see Superman being good his
wholesomeness all of that juxtaposed
against brainiacs pure evil trying to
take over things I want to see a
different kind of ill-informed man I
want to see a classic villain I want to
see a visually stunning villain and the
only one of those is brainy because
again the teen boom time alright Dan I
agree I want to see a light-hearted
Superman I want to see Superman take on
a villain that's gonna challenge him but
isn't gonna try to destroy metropolis
destroy the world he's a trickster he's
somebody from another dimension it's
gonna come and try to shake things up
and I think you can do that mr. mix up
lick so you can make a mess around
Superman's life you can mess around with
Superman's friends again not every big
superhero movie has to be a trudge
through world-changing stakes and the
ultimate villain sometimes they can just
kind of be in 20 seconds whenever you
speak
I understand bizarro seems like a
ridiculous choice but this is the thing
I would do I would make him a much like
Brainiac a remnant of Krypton that it's
like a almost like a clone that's made
up of excess kryptonite stuff and
Superman stuff that made it somehow in
the birthing matrix and I think that
that villain of Superman of these movies
two feats that in front of everybody it
would show that look man I'll handle you
when evil stuff comes around I'm 10
second rebuttals I feel like mr. Becks
place is too much of a leap we're not
there yet it's kind of stake handed at
least have the evolution of the thing of
all that doomsday were definitely not
ready for emeriti kind of had that the
first two movies I like the way they did
both of those characters were dooms they
asked a Jew's day was very someone in so
we're not ready for those mine yeah I
think we're at a point with Superman
he's in a rebirth it doesn't matter what
the cannon is you have a new version on
the character we saw that in Justice
League and I don't want another
Kryptonian rebirth into matrix rebirth
we had that was odd
had that with doomsday I don't want
another room then of Krypton this is
horrible and it seems like I'm almost
advocating but damn it bizarro is cool
he talks cool and he's funny and
Brainiac is a hard sell because of all
the technology and frankly midsi's
pedelec I just don't get it time Wow at
the end of the day like I thought these
were all great and any one of them could
have won but at the end of the day I
thought we we brought down IDI with with
those arguments as far as Brainiac in my
head and I was like it is a to
Kryptonian is a 2k boom you got it yeah
good job
Wow well it's not decided yet so I would
say IDI does not move on even though I
really enjoyed his answer Danielle as
much as I enjoyed your answer and as
soon as anytime someone says I'm given
up and you you take yourself yeah
alright well ed well fought all the way
through sadly you will not be moving on
to the speed round
but yes valiant effort good sir it's
speed round time y'all like mines as
always Rania alright so no points were
awarded in that tiebreak it was just a
tie-break to see you makes it and it is
1-1 damn coy going to the speed round
and again same rules as we just did
first answer out speaks first they get
twenty seconds to ten second rebuttal
after that
there we go gentlemen y'all ready do it
alright and same judges apply alright
question number one
Oh from one of our women and film donors
our good friend dev which is the better
film the French Connection or Serpico
my french connection okay that means we
can say arguing for Serpico all right
let me talk a little classics Dan you
answered first 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak one of the things about the
great things about the French Connection
is it's a great example of the 70s of
taking what should be a heroic figure
and kind of showing different sights
impediment to making the antihero that's
what you have with Popeye Doyle he's a
cop but he doesn't play by the rules but
not in the night in the shorts a nagger
way and the fact that the good guy
spoilers doesn't always have to win in
the end it's averted that trope and it
showed you that it's about the
investigation it was about the
criminality I agree is what he said
except for I think mine also did a great
ante here I think it does not only
change what police figures are CNN's it
also changed our opinion about Pacino it
redefined a very important actor of the
time it also redefined a very important
honor for the time I think this
redefined what police can be in film I
remember that just for the chase scene I
don't know anything else Serpico is
remembered from many many things in the
nuanced opportunities Florence Jean
axles just say that performance I didn't
think it was that much and this movie
allowed us to evolve into what happened
she was becomes attack Gene Hackman won
an Oscar for this performance Pacino's
performance while good blends into the
rest of us performs from the 70s I don't
think it's one of his better ones and
again dirty cops is nothing new but the
fact that this guy is still fighting for
good and the fact that I always feel
like an Oscar is enough the movies are
as memorable because I think of the
chasing I don't think of the performance
when I think of Serpico I think of
everything in the film I don't think
just one item and out Pacino's province
is way more than just a dirty cop
they're sort of serving those records as
these are I'm wow well played well
played let's start with lungs two great
films two great arguments but I think
ultimately quois argument sort of came
down to French Connection is just that
chase I just really on a fundamental
level don't agree there's so much great
stuff in that movie
Hoffman's performance did win an Oscar
so I got to go with Dan on this one all
right
that's one for Dan Daniel why are we all
letting koi turn us into micro machines
I you know I actually I have to disagree
I your laughs yeah laughs um you're
right that it isn't just about the chase
and you know what I like no I agree no I
just reread the arguments over on my
laptop and I do have to agree I don't
know that I agree with the argument that
the Oscar Oscar isn't necessarily enough
I do think it is enough okay at this
point I'm not sure whether all right
thank you
there we go that is a point for Dan it
is to one Dan going to question two from
the speed round again four points is
what will take the victory today this is
another question from a women in film
donor our friend Kim what's the best
non-disney animated film hmm that's
non-disney animated movie an American
tale American tale I don't know if this
counts can I pre Disney sale Toy Story
because Pixar made it before they were
owned by Disney oh yeah I feel like it
was distributed by the time it was done
and made it was distributed by okay so
oh no something else yeah damn Disney
kind of runs the game How to Train Your
Dragon it's all right
that's an American town versus How to
Train Your Dragon Dan spoke first 20
seconds begins when you speak now beyond
just being a great animated film I think
that it is a great story it is the tale
of immigration into America and it
actually tale it tells a very complex
story about a Jewish expulsion and
acceptance the melting pot that is
America that immigrant experience told
to the tale of an animated mouse it's
got the timeless search for my family
it's got great music it's got a great
story great vocal performances
How to Train Your Dragon does the
impossible it makes you care about not
only dragons but Vikings and a time that
like we've seen all of these things but
you care about acceptance you care about
what children feel the whole movie you
feel like a leper you feel like you're
put out of the world this movie makes
you feel like you want to know these
characters it makes you care about both
sides of this divide and it makes you
understand like when something is the
last of something it's important and you
want to coddle it you want to warm it
like I feel like How to Train Your
Dragon is a fantasy I feel like an
American tale is something that hits
home for everybody and I feel like How
to Train Your Dragon was one up - by its
own sequel How to Train Your Dragon - as
much as I love Fievel goes west it
doesn't hold a candle to an American
tale I don't think American tale holds
up as well as we remember it being
whereas I think as I get older How to
Train Your Dragon just becomes more
important because I think accepting
others is the message of both films but
I think how to trainer dragons it does
it across species which shows a greater
depth of what that movie is time Wow
okay good arguments you know what I got
to go with that I got to go down on this
the selling us the the fiber of the
movie and I feel like we just yeah and
then knocking it down with its own
sequel yeah my point is for Dan let's go
too long yeah I agree I just felt like
Dan's in a better job selling me on like
what specifically makes an American tale
sort of vital and memorable whereas I
think core made a lot of good points but
you could sort of say a lot of that
about pretty much any beloved animated
film I thought the specificity of Dan's
argument really made it there we go Dan
gets that point and it is three one Dan
so this is a game point coy you need
this to keep it going down you take this
you take the game all right this week
marks the 30th anniversary of die hard
who's the best supporting character from
the original movie that means no Bruce
Willis no Alan Rickman any other
character of the cop comes to the cop
for his name loud yeah al Powell yeah
okay now pal Reginald veljohnson
[Laughter]
Carl all right we have al Powell versus
Carl coy you spoke first 20 seconds
begin when you speak now al hell's the
everyman of this film he's the guy you
relate to he's your eyes and I love that
in a movie about cops the cop is the one
you're rooting for them there's a
vigilante kind of doing his thing
Bruce Willis is the guy doing all the
cool crazy lines were the whole time you
wonder what the cops doing and I love
that he's just like this beating heart
of the film that doesn't get enough love
and appreciation he's every eye line
through the film and without him the
movie doesn't work because then the rest
is just action you need the grounded to
have the action that gem claim is that
what you see the eye the eyes of the
movie throughout Powell is a nice side
character that he gets to talk to his
down moments but what I love about Carl
is he's almost the ultimate evil in that
movie Hans kind of fails at everything
he does for Carl it's personal he's the
big bad at the end of the movie people
forget that he doesn't really fight Hans
he just kind of pushes him out of window
Carl is the guy that that John McClane
has to defeat in order to survive
there's the Emperor and there's Vader
you remember Vader Hans is the number
one in that movie and I really feel like
the heart of the film is more important
than this secondary bad at the end of
the day he's and secondary bad it does
matter which one's bigger he's a follow
up the are a part of the film is my
character and I love that that's a cop
Hans is the Emperor and Carl is Darth
Vader and you remember Darth Vader
I like the friendly cop but I'm gonna go
with the badass henchman as the better
character every time well playing again
Danielle oh yeah that was a fantastic
argument but coy really had me with the
stuff about being the heart of the film
so I'm gonna go with that you know what
I absolutely agree dan made a really
great case for Carl but I feel like coy
was just unbeatable in the way he laid
that out so yeah I'm also going coy it
is three two
I didn't know his name this didn't come
up in that conversation at least nobody
said Oracle's neighbor all right this
question is a real Sophie's Choice and
has nothing to do with the movie
Sophie's Choice again it's three to Dan
takes this he takes the game coy takes
us he ties it up in honor of M night
Shyamalan glass simple question Samuel
Jackson or Bruce Willis Samuel Jackson
alright had to fall by default you get
Bruce Willis all right Dan you go first
for Sam Jackson twenty six begins
whatever you speak I had a long-standing
theory that people don't love Bruce
Willis they love John McClane however
people effing love a samuel at Jackson
so much that he is Samuel Jackson more
than he has any other character that he
has played he has been a prestige actor
from the 80s the 90s the to thousands of
2010s what's bruce willis doing
direct-to-video what samuel jackson
doing oh I'm sorry he's only one of the
anchoring characters of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I agree with her
pointing the opposite I think that
Samuel Jackson can only play Samuel
Jackson whereas Bruce Willis - The Sixth
Sense and John McLean are two very
different roles he can play drama he can
play comedy and you can count them to be
a good action star you can count on
Samuel Jackson do one thing that's me
Samuel Jackson you can count on Bruce
Willis to bringing tickets just as much
but also be multi-faceted he's a better
actor he's got more range and he's got
the same versatility and badassness but
he can be other things as well those are
the two Bruce Willis from other movies
it's die hard and Sixth Sense I can give
you Pulp Fiction I can give you the
member of the scene from coming to
America I can give you Nick Fury I can
give you any number deep blue sea you
made the great shark movie that's why
deep blue sea is great it's not the
shark now see I disagree mercury rising
Hudson Hawk there's so many different
depths to this man he's got a lot going
on I know those are movies that are
revered in the same way but they achieve
different ranges of acne because they're
not known doesn't mean they don't count
Bruce Willis has more to him Wow all
right
man how about it you know when he said
Mercury Rising I really had to stop and
be like wait what was mercury rising III
think you made some great points just
like as far as Bruce Willis capturing
certain roles but I thought Dan laid out
just a unbeatable salvo for me I'm going
down on this one long well I actually
disagree I think I think Dan came out to
it really early but McCoy really sold me
by the end I really like the versatility
and I also I don't know if I've ever
voted for anyone in the speedrun who
brought up Hudson ok Daniel Radford it's
1:1 what are you thinking I as great as
both of these arguments are I have to go
with Dan on this one I thought that he
just by thought even made a better
points plus no LL Cool J's deep Lucy
song stuck in my head
there you go Dan you take to the
proverbial limits
[Applause]
you feel goat up against a felted friend
for the belt I say I do not
underestimate this belted friends
however felted friend you have my belt
and I'm coming for it
so get used to it shine it up sleep next
to it whatever you need to do is coming
back with me would you call the felted
enemy now that seems mean that's a
little opponent Dan well fought today
well played as for used coin nicely done
[Applause]
but you crushed it throughout please go
ahead and plug some stuff tell us where
you can find yeah I like you find me on
Twitter and Instagram at core John Doe
you can find me on my show Marlboro news
on Tuesdays I want to Collider heroes on
Mondays I love being here we got a thing
coming out soon about like ant-man yes
and I just like I'm just accept like
screen junkies this this the spot feels
good like I love this fight it just felt
good to like have this argument with
people that I like arguing movies but
like the magical about the internet is
this is like relevant attention like we
also talked about for the other French
Connection yeah piece of narration now
get some lovely some Netflix it's hard
if not fine find it thank you sir and I
always love it when you come by and you
did such a fantastic job
you know these tell us some stuff where
you can find get plug some stuff I mean
honestly I really felt like John Henry
in here with these guys
you're fighting you're fighting machines
and you're barely you're barely holding
on but I do a podcast called nerd goat
which I'm very proud of it's a five-star
rated podcast with a bunch of reviews
we're so five-star ratings so it must be
doing something well and we just take
interesting people and talk to them
about their favorite fictional
characters of all time their nerd
greatest of all time we're gonna have
everybody from screen junkies on it at
some point and it's just really
interesting and I'm gonna be on Comedy
Central
later this year on the show called new
Negroes and you can say it and it's yeah
it'll be my television debut yeah and so
yeah so it's this has been a really good
thing being here at screen junkies every
Wednesday and contributing to some of
their videos and stuff maybe doing some
more now that things are settled so yeah
I I love this place and I thank you guys
for the opportunity to show sure let us
sure we got well we're lucky to have you
know dudes like you and just ever I mean
I feel lucky to just be around such
thoughtful smart nerdy people so thank
you as well for being here Long's thank
you good stuff you know hanging around
screen junkies videos all the time we've
got some fun stuff coming out so uh
that's where to go oh heck yeah yeah and
the fabulous and talented Danielle
Radford um so yeah just find me on all
the social also for folks who've been
asking about my Comic Con schedule I
will be putting that up I'm still
waiting for things get finalized but
yeah if you're gonna be around come out
come see things I will be around awesome
and yeah I want to thank you for
watching on how rudnick you can follow
me on Twitter and Instagram let's talk
movies let's just like shoot breeze
about some fun crap on Twitter and
Instagram at Hal Rudnick and yeah what a
fun time looking forward to that
filtered friend matchup more the belt
and thanks again for watching uh see you
next time bye bye
you